chi-chi gonzalez making just his third
start of the year but i'm gonna go to
what he's done in his career against the
dodgers when he's faced the dodgers we
have seen the best of chichi
in the air to charlie deep right and he
reaches up and makes the grab one out
muncie
and this is a line drive off the
end of the back grab by story two outs
back to back two out base runners for
the dodgers
i'm one of the hottest dodger hitters
taylor
pokes one down the right field line
that'll drop in for a base hit and give
the dodgers the early lead turners into
score bellinger will come in as well on
a
two-run double for chris taylor he
actually goes to third
see how they rule that
with the throw going to the plate
taylor with rbi's number 19 and 20 in
the month of september
32 year old left-hander clayton kershaw
making his ninth start of the year
five and two in the era of 228. toppy at
second nobody out palma with another 2-2
to get stories swinging with the slider
topia takes off for third and the throw
is high and top is in there pretty
interesting list we'll share with you a
little bit later see now you get a run
home
that bag pays off tapia with a leg
double steals third and scores on a
ground out and it's a two to one ball
game
flies the first pitch to left
aj pollock
makes the catch and ends the inning man
out of puerto rico
2-2 is strike three calls as quinn
wolcott
got him swinging to finish off the
ending faces the minimum
dodgers with the 2-1 lead
chi-chi gonzalez struggled in the first
and
he's held the dodgers at bay in a fly
ball to center field racing on back
is polari looks up and it's gone
well chris taylor in his first two bats
has tripled he has homered and now he's
a single and a double away from a cycle
how about that
just starting pitching
with some guys missing starts has been
unreal
[Applause]
grounded a third backhand rios jump
throw across the line to get a speedy
runner for the first out of the fifth
that rios gets better and better the
defensive side of the ball that was a
beautiful little play
kershaw gets him swinging with a good
slider
fourth one for kershaw two up two down
in the fifth
another payoff
kept down swinging a backdoor slider to
finish the rockies off in the fifth
that's 11 straight retired by kershaw
who leads 3-1 but a solid start of three
runs five innings from
chichi gonzalez
we can't tell did he
he did
nicely done josh fuentes
aj pollock leads it off
[ __ ] hammers the ball to right field
that sends blackman back aj pollock with
an opposite field home run
number 12 of the season for pollock and
the dodgers lead 4-1
oh look out here comes barnes ricochets
right back to butera but barnes is in
safely
that's the third
he's not gonna stop he's coming home and
he will beat the throw
mookie bets lightning to the plate and
it's six one
he got him to chase strike three
kershaw's sixth k one gone in the
seventh out of the stretch mcgee's o2
gets a chase for strike three and the
first down to the eighth kentley jansen
comes out with a 6-1 lead
strikes him out on three pitches
tapio with a leaping play at third by
edwin rios
climbing the ladder for out number two
in the ninth inning
jensen ready
here's his 1-2 pitch
line to right center field bellinger's
there and the dodgers beat the rockies
6-1 for their fifth consecutive win
and a tidy two hours and 32 minutes at
coors field